what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Robert and
I believe I figured out the title for
Avengers 4 so without going through a
very big huge diatribe we'll do that in
a minute
I think the title for Avengers 4 is
infinite Avengers I think that's what
they're calling it
now here's the reason why I say that
there's been a lot of theories that have
thrown out there and as far as I'm aware
infinite Avengers hasn't necessarily
been or it hasn't been debunked by by
the Russo brothers I'm sure I'm not the
first person to ever think of it but I
don't think it was Devon it has been
debunked by the by the Russo brothers
they turned down Avengers 4 Infinity
Gauntlet Avengers 4 Avengers
disassembled and Avengers 4 avengers
forever like day they turn down those
titles but they said that Avengers
Forever is the closest one and I was
thinking about that and I was like man
like if it's an if it's if Avengers
Forever is the closest thing to the
title and they said that like elements
of Avengers for the avengers forever are
essentially part of the story then
there's only one other conclusion that I
can draw and that's Infinite Avengers so
here's the reason why Marvel movies
follow they follow the old Stanley Jack
Kirby style of storytelling to be honest
I mean if that's really what they are
those you guys who don't know back when
Jack Kirby and Stan Lee really helped to
like turn Marvel into the powerhouse
that it is now back in the 60s and the
early 70s for the most part every comic
was basically self-contained you would
have a couple instances where you would
have like a three-issue story but for
the most part within the span of you
know 22 - you know what we're really
like you know 19 to 25 pages basically
it was a complete story is really what
it was and especially when it came to
things like the introduction of Iron Man
the return of Captain America the
introduction of Thor the Avengers so on
and so forth it was here's the star of
the comic and this is their origin story
you know or what they haven't even doing
at the time if it's moved past their
origin but in the case of the MCU it's
adapting the old origin story so here is
here's who Tony Stark is and here's how
Tony Stark got his suit and here's why
Tony Stark got his suit and here's his
main enemy here's Tony Stark fighting
him Tony Stark wins done like that's
that's it's the it's it's a method this
worked for Marvel Comics for years and
in truth like it's a method that works
for the MCU you don't become the most
financially successful film franchise
not adjusted for inflation by you know
by doing things that don't really work
if that makes any sense the system works
for them and they're usually popular
because of it but the truth is the truth
is when you look at infinity war it's
basically the first half of a whole film
what they did with an infinity war would
be like if they took black panther and
they split the movie in half and black
panther part one ended with Eric hill
monger defeating T'Challa throwing him
off a cliff and then ascending to the
rhone to the throne of Black Panther
that would be like how infinity war
ended and then Black Panther two would
be when T'Challa comes back so sure
infinity war didn't necessarily follow
the formula that the heroes always lose
to a tee but we know that an Avengers
for the the yeah the the villains will
lose rather you know the follow the
formula the villains were always loose
we know what if interest for that Thanos
will lose I mean these will have to go
back to the way they were before but
this is the reason why I think it's it's
it's you know infinite Avengers one of
my favorite Avengers runs of all time is
why guy named Jonathan Hickman Jonathan
Hickman the Wrights like these super
complex stories and they stretch on and
on and on for like three years I mean
they're they're insane how long that
could last for and his Avengers a New
Avengers Ron it dealt with something
called the incursions if you know this
story bear with me my channel grew by
60,000 subscribers in 14 days there's a
ton of new people here and while we
don't know anything about comics the
incursions were basically Marvel's way
of telling the story of how the
multiverse was going to end and all-new
all-different marvel was going to kick
off to make it pretty short what you
ended up finding out is there was a race
called the beyonders and they had this
grand experiment that we're gonna create
a being called the molecule man Owen
Reese and they were gonna put one
version of him in every single universe
and no one Reese is super powerful he
could control the molecular structure of
matter really control atoms but the fact
remains the goal of the beyonders was to
detonate all the molecule men at one
time and blow up the multiverse just to
see what happened there an incoming book
adaptation of Mythbusters is really what
they were the result is that dr. doom
the villain of the Fantastic Four and
the main Marvel Universe Owen Reese
realized what was going on and their
idea was to go into the multiverse and
to stop this from happening they ended
up screwing up they killed the molecule
man in a different universe and the
result was that that universe exploded
and when it did it pushed the two
universes next to it into the universes
next to them and so was this cascading
effect it was just BAM
and bamm-bamm and the universe has kept
crashing into each other and that was
called the incursions uh what ended up
happening is you had a group called the
Illuminati which at the time that story
was written was Captain America dr.
strange iron man name of the Submariner
black panther black ball of the Inhumans
and beast Hank McCoy of the x-men and
they ended up coming together with the
Infinity stones because the Illuminati
had this idea that the Infinity stones
are too powerful for any one person to
wield in its totality so they split the
gems up amongst amongst each other and
said that they will hold them but never
use them only in a time of dire need and
you know when your universe is about to
be destroyed it's kind of a time of dire
need and so because of that they brought
the Infinity stones together they
reformed the Infinity Gauntlet they gave
it to Captain America they said here you
go Captain America you willed it because
you know freedom whatever and so Captain
America used the Infinity Gauntlet to
try to push one of the universes away it
didn't work all the gyms shattered like
they thought they were all totally
destroyed except for the time stone the
time stone just vanished it disappeared
into the times the time stream and we
didn't find out what happened for it or
what happened to it for something like
50 issues fast-forward over the course
of those 50 issues the time stone
returns and it Yanks I think captain I
know it's Captain America I think it's
Black Widow and I think it's Hawkeye and
it yanked them and it starts taking them
like into the future so the first thing
is like 50 years into the future the
second thing is 100 years in the future
after that it's like a thousand and then
50,000 and someone a so forth but that
whole time-traveling hit a
time-traveling caper with Captain
America and those guys that's an
Avengers vol 6 Avengers vol 6 is called
infinite Avengers now why do I think
that because there's one thing you just
throw a theory out there it's another to
have some sort of evidence for it the
evidence is slim it's it's pretty thin
when it comes to Marvel movies the proof
is always in the credits usually the end
credits scene or something like that is
when they do that the great big huge
drop when people sit at the end of
infinity war no one watches the credits
they wait until the end credits or the
mid-credits scene but no one looked at
the names that are scrolling no one
looks at neo all the things that are
going on and they certainly don't look
at the title at the end of the movie if
you go back and you watch infinity work
all the credits roll right before the
post credits scene it says Avengers
infinity war all the letters fade except
for I a and to me it's infinite Avengers
although now I say it that is a really
slim and
in theory but I think it I think would
be infinite of interest and here's a
reusing other reason why the Russo
brothers when they were going through
and they were debunking all these
different you know names that were given
avengers forever they said is the
closest one now here's a point of
avengers forever avengers forever was a
story that was written in the 1990s and
i'm pretty sure it was a 1990s and it
dealt with a villain called immortus if
you don't know who he is
it doesn't matter and mortis sucks
anyway the whole point of the story was
that it was basically the avengers of
the past the present and the future all
being brought together
by a singular but really by like book
Jones if you don't know who he is it
doesn't matter either but they were
basically was it basically all the
Avengers from the past the present in
the future or at least the most popular
ones who were brought together to face
off against immortus now Marvel repeated
that in a story called Ultron forever
which I don't remember we only remember
what issues that cross but it was
basically the same thing that Ultron had
conquered the world and in fact that
story came out of Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers where it showed a future were
Ultron conquered the world and replaced
all the Avengers with robots and so it
was it was kind of cool it was
interesting like everybody was basically
robots except for humans there were
small human encampments of people who
hadn't been wiped out yet but the fact
remains here that when the Russo
brothers say Avengers forever is the
closest thing to the title my thought is
that is drawing on elements of Avengers
forever which they said like elements
are gonna be in there and if elements of
Avengers forever gonna be in there then
what it means is it seems to me and it
seems to be the most reasonable
conclusion but if we're not gonna see
cosmic entities which I still want to do
Theory videos about cosmic entities I
don't really care but if we're not gonna
see like the letting Tribunal or any of
those entities and it means it is quite
literally on the shoulders of the
superhero community to come together in
to defeat Thanos well we know from the
ending of infinity war that's gonna be a
very difficult task and it stands to
reason that like you could bring them
all together because here's a funny
thing the time stone spans like the
Infinity stones really the time stone
time stone specifically spans all time
in any one universe we'll probably talk
about that when we talk about the Living
Tribunal 22 years of reading comics I'll
learn new things every day I just
learned about like Universal dimensional
and physical energy and the Marvel
actually lays out how magic works and
they did actually explain the purpose of
the Living Tribunal and Avenger I'm
sorry in Fantastic Four number 500 so I
had no idea that that was the case but
the fact remains here the when it comes
to the time stone it spans all time in
any one particular universe
you can travel from the very beginning
of the universe to the very ends of the
universe and everywhere in between using
the time stone
just because Thanos has the Infinity
stones in the present doesn't mean he'll
have them in the future and it doesn't
mean that like you know that they won't
be brought back it'd be very easy for
someone in like five years you know five
years in the future to grab the time
stone the Illuminati or anybody to grab
the time stone and jump back to the
modern day and basically say like hey we
all have to like like I've gathered all
these superheroes so basically like
travel throughout the past in the
present Avengers in the past Avengers in
the present day Avengers in the future
the whole nine yards bring them all
together and they all faced off against
Thanos and this I think is an actual is
a really cool idea and here's the reason
why
infinite it like Avengers four is
supposed to be like a jumping on
platform to the next phase of the MCU
what better way to do that than to grab
the characters or some of the characters
that will appear in phase four and bring
them into Avengers 4 you never don't
really find anything out about it like
you have moon night you know and moon
nights kind of interesting moon if
you're not a fan of Batman then moon
nights definitely Batman if you are a
fan of Batman moon night is not Batman
it depends on who you're talking to
um but you know munites got most
personalities and you know it's like
what is it March Spectre Steve Grant and
I always forget the last one I always
say the last one is moon night but
that's not that's not true there's a
third personality I'm pretty sure and we
just did the story like like seven
months ago so I don't remember I don't
never who the third personality is I
keep one to say Jamie Oliver but he's a
chef so um like go like you could grab
those characters like Moon Knight you
here's another thing you could do too
you could say that like Miles Morales is
spider-man in five years and just Bri
miles more Alison you know you have like
Miles Morales and he's the spider-man in
Avengers 4 it'd be a great way to like
introduces care to literally test the
waters and see how people respond to
that kind of stuff it'd be a genius
thing to pull off because what you do is
you basically get this new set of
Avengers it lives it lives up to like
the New Avengers concept it plays the
plot of Avengers forever and then is
titled Infinite Avengers and they all
basically merge together to give us
Avengers for I don't know I mean at this
point when it comes to these things I'm
spitballing I have no real idea no one
does
Marvel is playing it's so hush-hush oh
my god the playing is so close to the
vest when it comes to that movie they're
not telling us
so about what's going on but let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section I'm pretty curious um I know you
guys have like a lot of theories of your
own on what happens I've been reading
through them like in these videos that
I've been doing because I usually never
do these on on DC days I usually always
do these on Tuesdays Thursdays and
Saturdays when I do Marvel content but I
honestly didn't want to let this go I
just want to like throw this out there
cuz it's been bugging me I've been up
since 3:30 in the morning and it's been
bugging me ever since I first you know
first first crossed my mind but uh yeah
like let me know what you guys think
because I'm curious to see what you guys
end up coming up with and yeah I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]